or some analysis now let's bring in
Guido Steinberg he's a Middle East
expert from the German Institute for
International and security affairs here
in Berlin good Co Guiteau so if I know
let's look at it is in Syria how close
are we to do Singh is defeated in Syria
is is defeated in Syria ha Jean has been
the last major stronghold of the
organization so that by now the
organization doesn't control any
territory any town anymore what we have
seen in recent days is a big success for
the SDF and for the Americans if is is
defeated in Syria and you suggest that
they are for all practical purposes what
becomes of that notorious jihadist
movement is will they simply melt away
or can we expect them to go on wreaking
havoc elsewhere they have melted away
but they have they have turned into an
underground movement already in
neighboring Iraq and I suspect that
something similar might happen in Syria
in the coming months and years because
we do not see the different conflicts in
in the country ending and that is why
the organization will have its
opportunities to continue operating but
on a rather local or perhaps regional
scale and that is why we have seen the
big attacks being reduced in Europe in
recent years now our report suggests
that Turkish forces in Syria might end
up attacking the Kurds in Syria who've
been instrumental in defeating I asked
why would turkey do that is turqu is
turkey more interested in fighting kurds
than it is in defeating ions exactly
from the turkish point of view the SDF
is controlled by the PYD and the PYD
according to the turks is an integral
part of the turkish organization PKK
they are right about that and that is
why they threatened the Kurds in Syria
with this attack they have already taken
parts of Kurdish territories in in
spring 2018 in Afreen and now
might they might attack eastern Syria as
well they take the PKK or a PYD a lot
more seriously than they take Isis
seriously as a threat to the Turkish
Republic Peter thank you so much for
your insight skeeter Steinberg Middle
East expert from the German Institute
for international and security affairs
in BRR